it's not uncommon to be using the bia
scale to be in a calorie deficit to lose
some weight and you know maybe it's the
start of a diet you've lost
five pounds six pounds something like
that and your bia scale say it says oh
hey like you've only lost six pounds but
guess what four of those are muscle and
then you say oh [ __ ] that's bad i've
barely lost any weight i'm all i'm
already just shedding lean mass not
losing much fat at all this is going
catastrophically bad and that's based on
the assumption that the same day
reliability of bia extrapolates to
uh like reliably tracking changes over
time but the reason it's probably not
going to do that
is because of basically the way bia
works so
um
like muscle uh and
lean tissue in general tends to be
better hydrated than fat tissue is like
it has more water content
and so
it's basically trying to pick up on
water content and use that to
extrapolate body composition
and so
let's say you start a diet you go into a
caloric deficit that's probably going to
come with a reduction in carbohydrate
intake uh you know and you lose a little
muscle glycogen that decreases the the
hydration of muscle tissue bia is going
to pick up on that
as a
loss in lean mass and a smaller
reduction in fat mass than actually
happened uh and so yeah it's going to
say you lost a lot of muscle you didn't
actually lose a lot of muscle you just
lost some of the water content in your
muscles but
bia has no way of knowing that uh and
also
since a bia scale is just passing that
electro
electrical current through your legs it
can't know what's happening in your
upper body so
you know maybe
based on what it can see the body
composition of your legs looks about the
same um but maybe you're losing a ton of
abdominal fat or visceral fat or fat off
of your upper body there's literally no
way for your bia scale to know that
that's happening and it's just going to
look and say like well you know i'm
seeing about the same resistance to this
electrical current in the legs so uh it
doesn't seem like body comp is changing
all that much
you know maybe similar amounts of muscle
and fat is being lost that's not the
case uh but
the the technology itself has no way of
picking up on that um
so yeah like bia scales might be
might give you repeatable measurements
on the same day
but due to the limitations of the
technology it is probably not going to
reliably track changes in body comp over
time or tell you particularly reliably
how much fat versus muscle you're losing
in a deficit or how much fat versus
muscle you're gaining in a surplus same
day reliability and reliably tracking
changes over time
similar concepts different things bia
scales are pretty good at the former not
so much at the latter so
um yeah if if
every indication is that your diet is
going well you know your your
performance in the gym seems to be
keeping up you don't visibly look in the
mirror like you're shedding a ton of
muscle but your scale says oh man you're
down six pounds but you've already lost
five pounds of muscle just ignore it it
it is
giving you a very rough estimation of
changes it is not measuring changes and
that's that's a very important
distinction
so yeah i mean
i
i personally think that
body fat percentage estimates from bia
scales are
are
less than worthless
because if they end up being
correct it's pretty much by chance and
if they end up tracking changes in body
composition
reliably incorrectly that's also more or
less by chance
like there
so i i don't think they
give you reliable enough correct
information to actually be useful but
there's a very high chance that they're
going to give you
information that
will mislead you about what's actually
going on
so
you know you don't get anything
beneficial from it it might [ __ ] with
your head
i personally think you should just
ignore it and if you have a smart scale
that is supposed to
assess your body fat percentage you
generally have to stay stepping on it a
little bit longer before it will
actually take that measurement just wait
until the weight number comes up record
that step the [ __ ] off the scale like
don't don't even look at the body fat
percentage number it is not telling you
anything valuable